um so I got a couple of points boost as
well nice yeah Vincent he's uh just
super strong and he's a man in form yeah
now no longer a student a full-time
chess professional yeah and with the
white pieces against Magnus what's uh
happening on the board the English
opening maybe another of us here in the
studio but this last move uh major
chocolate Lawrence D3 I think
griststroke was the one who uh
popularized it a few years ago I think
kramnik also had a few outings with this
a few years back it's a very
um it's it's a move which says to Black
you've got lots of options here but I
want a non-theoretical battle and I just
want to get a position that's playable
against you so it's quite an interesting
approach
um
and something I don't recall Vincent
doing previously actually he has that or
has he yeah he has but uh just uh only
last month September the Sabbath he beat
Nils grandelius with this variation what
was that in was that in and over the
board tournament or it was and the
Polish extra Liga this is the tournament
where Vincent had a tremendous score
and uh and where he reached 2700 yeah
yeah so by hook or by cook we've got
what looks like a normal position it's
just uh it's kind of an odd uh kind of
version of one so right now Black's
Bishop has come out nicely white has
placed his Bishop his own dark Square
Bishop on an odd Square white is just
not neglected I mean he's neglected to
develop his King side pieces so far
white needs to get castled at some point
somebody expecting Vincent to kind of
Remedy that and just bring out some of
those King side pieces now but yeah I
mean this is just a strange strategy to
me it's like Magnus is the one who tries
his hardest to take players out of
theory you've kind of done his job for
him you've just given him a very healthy
position it looks like a sicilian just
with reverse colors
and Magnus he's the master of those
types of positions well it's quite
interesting you say that David because
um up until up until the pawn move where
it's that supported the bishop it was
all Theory but I mean had been played
before wasn't well known but once that
move had been played that was it new
territory and uh it's Vincent who is on
his own but of course as David
referenced they will be drawing all the
patterns that they learned when they are
when they themselves are playing the
Sicilian Defense with the white pieces
and yeah Magnus the master in this but I
can tell you Vincent kymer is a master
in Advantage capitalization I really
want to bring up the aim chess
head-to-head stats between these two
because Magnus Carlsen we know his
numbers are really high in everything
but Advantage capitalization Vincent
kaimer has the highest number of any of
the players in the tournament so in the
hundred last rapid games he has played
91 what's that mean so Advantage
capitalization here means when a player
has a plus two Advantage according to
the computer or more they convert and he
does that 91 of the time that is
phenomenal wow even in complicated
positions where the evaluation is
swinging he tends to win
um he doesn't really let things slip and
the other side of that is
resourcefulness when you're losing but
then you fight back and it starts there
are still decent also accuracy Vincent
almost at the same level as Magnus
that's incredible uh and game 69 is a
great number as well winning end games
uh at a decent rate so yeah good player
aha very very good player he gets an
advantage we need to Magnus needs to be
careful yeah and you know Vincent I
don't know how much you've spoken about
him here
um over the course why haven't you seen
every single minute I
was down the gym
um
Vincent has been working closely with
Peter leco which a lot of people may or
may not know Peter leco almost became
world champion in 2004. oh yeah great
players somebody I've actually done
commentary with on the other channel for
just 24 when I was uh doing some
commentary and uh imitates his style
very much he's uh very clinical player
doesn't he doesn't risk too much uh
that's he's not a gunslinger he's not a
mama jar of he's not a a dude well
perhaps
yeah he's a he's he he doesn't give you
many chances and when he gets a little
nibble he's got a really he's actually
incredibly mature his playing style is
he's only 17 but he plays like somebody
who's been playing chess for 50 years
it's quite extraordinary an old soul
he's got an old soul exactly it sounds
like you almost described Anish giri a
little bit but maybe what Anish is
struggling with is
taking the advantage when he has it
I think with an Angel so he does
struggle with uh uh
on how not understanding that's a bit
patronizing but he he doesn't like
risking at all and there are some
situations where you have to do it and
you have to be a bit more bold and a bit
more ambitious I think that's what's
held Anish back actually from getting to
the very very top yeah
so much of a perfectionist maybe just
hates losing
sometimes as we say you've got to risk
it for the biscuit you need to love
winning more than you hate losing yeah
and Magnus takes huge risks actually if
you look at his games wacky openings
random positions he takes massive risks
and he gets rewarded so you can't keep
control in throughout an entire game in
chess to get at this level you have to
do something unexpected and uh yeah
Vincent's capable of that I like you
said lecco and Vincent just it's so
clean not just yeah it's just never
really a big mess it's never as if
they've lost full control
um it's you know it's just impressive
there's one key difference though I have
noticed between someone like say a niche
and a Magnus and slash Vincent is that
both of these players um Vincent and
Magnus they start off from a
strategically sound opening even if
Magnus is playing something nonsense you
know there will be some kind of position
understanding some logic behind it
meanwhile a niche on the other hand he
tends to enter those complications very
early on you know he's not afraid of
playing these sharp variations so it's a
different type of risking there is you
know because when when Anish has been
asked to risk you know it literally
could be like a win or lose situation
for him if it doesn't go well meanwhile
the risk involved for Magnus is going to
be a lot less because he has that
Foundation
it's just a matter of style really yeah
yeah and I don't think you'd see a niche
for example uh someone like him play an
opening like this where Vincent just
takes the game into fresh territory from
what was it you said to vanco move three
move four it was brand new that position
already
um and she likes to know in advance what
he studied but Vincent that just shows
his confidence I guess to spar with
Magnus on a on his own level essentially
in his own comfort zone and meanwhile
okay just a trade of Bishop for night
that was expected and both sides
castling now so we've ended the opening
phase and we're just gonna get into that
maneuvering middle game white has the
two Bishops which I love but the center
is closed for now
any preference here which side would you
pick
I would take white I think ever so
slightly
the bishop pair has to count eventually
I agree with you there Lawrence and uh
whilst Vincent is thinking about his
move I wanted to share with you a selfie
that we have from Ardo who shares with
us that they are playing Beach Sunset
chess games with friends in Okinawa
Japan wish the broadcast team was here
yeah we we do too harder sounds nice
Beach Sunset chess nice sounds awesome
yeah and in Japan I've never been to
Japan it's like one of my dreams
destinations have you been there yeah I
loved it loved it yeah you've been I've
not I would I've been to a Japanese tea
garden in the middle of Berlin that's
very cool yeah I can't remember anybody
goes to Berlin there's a little sort of
sanctuary there but no that's about as
close as I've got to Japan
went in 2012. did you a long time ago
yeah with my family that's very nice
place did some palaces
found some underground underground like
gaming place where they were just uh
yeah so many strange they've got
Japanese shogi right very similar yeah
isn't that Peter heiner is a big fan
Peter heiner let's let's applaud Peter
heiner because he got to a very good
level now didn't he I think I don't know
the levels and shogi but I think you
know relatively speaking Yeah I think
you did all I know is that you're
supposed to sacrifice a lot of your
pieces in Shogun just attack attack so
it might suit me actually it's probably
crazy there's a lot of crazy stuff going
on in Japan we almost went uh
um Mario karting through the streets of
Tokyo because they have that wow yeah
you dress up as either Luigi or Mario or
whoever okay who are you gonna dress up
as
if you had a choice oh Yoshi maybe yeah
the green yeah what was it he was a frog
dragon dragon or a frog or Peach maybe
the Princess Peach to the princess yeah
yeah but yeah Japan very cool country
and we have some moves in this game
still
tense still tense uh it's still that
maneuvering face where both sides are
coming up with plans just trying to find
the best uh most active most promising
squares for their pieces yeah Magnus
just again this shows the nature of the
position just pushing a pawn creating
some breathing space for his King long
term that's a very long-term move and uh
Vincent maybe has the more
straightforward plan of the two but it
would come with risk if he rushes it so
if we jump in uh we see both sides just
laying out their territory and that's uh
kind of setting up their army here
after this last Pawn push I guess
magnus's idea is to bring his Bishop out
maybe Park his Bishop back here on a
nice safe square and uh for Vincent
because he is the one with the bishop
pair these two pieces he wants to open
up the position so long term either he's
got to play for this Pawn push to try
and lengthen the diagonal of this bishop
if things open up or he's got a build
for this Pawn push and uh this Pawn push
is impossible right now because after a
trade of Pawns this bishop is actually
hanging it's attacked twice
um so one idea for example would be to
just move the Rook across eventually
start getting ready for this Pawn push I
would be slightly tempted as well at
some point I'm not sure exactly when to
push this Pawn forward and then start
pushing here
but I was just thinking of that but I
didn't like giving up okay I've got a
wacky move for you daily hit me hit me
with it how but how bad do you like how
bad is the move King H1 here
that just to move Simon might approve if
the bishop comes out for example
you want to push this button yes
exciting the bishop and when the bishop
moves you want to shuffle your Rook
across yeah I have a feeling zero would
do I like it do you like it yeah you've
got my vote okay and I'm ashamed to say
that the move actually occurred to me
was what Vincent did in the end and then
I rejected it I said no you can't accept
you can't double your pawns close your
position this is very risky
strategically
um the problem is now this Pawn
this Pawn can never really be defended
by another Pawn uh Black's clamp down
here uh ensures that there's always
going to be on passant or always a
capture on this square if white ever
pushes his B Pawn forward therefore for
example black has an outpost for his
Knight or at least effectively an
outpost Black's Bishop can come and
attack this Pawn later on uh I would
envisage for example I guess White's
plan is to step forward at some point
but black can just always close this and
sit and wait long term maybe this one is
vulnerable I expect Magnus at some point
as well to relocate his Knight to a
better Square maybe this way
uh
yeah I mean white is basically all in on
an attack right now but I don't really
see it being that scary okay Magnus has
pushed this Pawn forward
it's a nice stable base from which to
play on
um because stable there forever and it's
going to be hard for a way to push
you also need a knight to jump into some
squares to if you really want to attack
but you have traded off your final
Knight it feels a bit impatient for
Vincent
but he does have two Bishops magna's
second game in a row where he does not
have his Bishop here haven't you said
that it's been a trend and because of is
it because of uh
artificial intelligence yeah um in
general Alpha zero for example this
position uh that we mentioned two moves
ago uh here it would come up with some
plan maybe a bit like Lawrence's it
would Shuffle the king in the corner do
some weird stuff but it would open the
position at the right time
and here although uh White does still
have the two Bishops the bishop pair if
we look sorry after magnus's move if we
look at the center it's extremely
blocked
um these pawns will never really
disappear uh this bishop is a terrible
piece and staring at its own pawns and
Magnus is indeed re-routing his Knight
um White had a threat actually of
dropping back and trying to win this
Pawn but now Magnus can simply defend it
with his Bishop
but yeah more importantly this Knight is
coming out to a dream square and you can
never kick it away from that
so Bishops are only good if the center's
open and that's not the case here aha
yeah
yeah no I I'm really liking magnus's
position and I do feel that Vincent has
to do something radical and that's why
he's given up a pawn
um
and he's winning it back immediately is
he not he's hits this rook and he's hit
the spawn at the same time Magnus blocks
Magnus pushes
um yeah he won back the pawn which is
very nice for Vincent but okay I guess
this may be a small issue
his style Square Bishop is so bad though
oh wow oh my gosh oh he can take and go
Queen D5 check yeah you're right massive
blunder is it huge Amanda and Vincent
has paused Magnus maybe hasn't realized
Bishop takes porn this is why just
knowing the evaluation at one point in
any chess game can be decisive this is a
check and a fork we hadn't spotted this
it's not immediately obvious but if you
get a nudge from the computer like this
with the evaluation
uh you find the winning move simply and
it does exist and seems like Vincent's
census the fact that he's paused me it
means it's on his radar so it looks like
automatic uh the bishop has to retreat
run away but then black is fine but
Bishop takes Pawn either you win a pawn
two Bishops or you win even more
with this double attack wow and magna's
not reacting if he's seen it is it
important that he that he does
Vincent trusts him maybe Vincent was
scared in this type of situation that
his Queen would be trapped in the corner
but it looks like it has plenty of
Escape squares it has squares to run to
what a Miss Mutual blindness we call it
when yeah I know the player just looks
for the tactic looks for the moment and
oh that was a huge moment I mean I
I can't blame Vincent I mean if we just
don't expect the world champion to
blunder like this it's quite a simple
blunder it's just a two move tactic but
if you're not expecting the moment it's
hard to pick up on it and uh now yeah
it's back to roughly equal
um black has these three pawns but some
double pawns here whereas white has a
five versus four advantage on the other
side
wow wow yeah a spectacular Mission and
actually uh Magnus does get away a lot
of the time because people just believe
that he can't make such blunders it's
Magnus Carlson
as if he would blunder a two-move tactic
but it does happen and
you know
um he got away with one big time just
there that that really was the end of
the game if you play Bishop takes B5
because then suddenly
The Black Queen so I just uh
dissipates into into nothingness so
great great miss there and now Magnus is
better again and when you miss a shot
like that against Magnus he's not going
to give you a second chance
so I fully expect now this to be a
Magnus Victory but a fairly long one
it's not it's going to take another 40
50 moves not the long grind ahead the
worst scenario is when you make your
move and just after you make your move
your brain goes but wait one second you
had you could have taken the pawn yes
and then you're like brain why did you
not work when I was thinking why wait
until after I've made my move that's
happens me so many times and you spend
the rest of the game just going
one yeah and it's not just the one about
winning is when you blunder something
you spent 20 minutes on that move and
you play a move and you end up playing
your movements oh that just loses
and you know just why am I playing this
game what am I doing how do you guys
react like when you know you've
blundered but your opponent hasn't moved
yet do you get up the poker face
yeah I just okay so now I know when I
play you yeah
I can't I can't just Magnus to go to
Poker Face who else has got a really
good Pokemon that just has a poker face
over the board but yes not online online
normally he reacts right yeah who's got
a good poker face over the board
Carolina yes it's like you never know
whether he's winning or losing just
looking at him no well Magnus did have a
great Poker Face in like game six in
2014 when he blundered Big Time against
Anand right and he had to sit there and
keep his poker face and then I didn't
notice the blunder it was not too porn
ah I was commentating
it's nearly 10 years yeah yeah and I've
recently blundered at the Olympiad I
thought it was winning on the spot I
played a move literally the moment I
left I my fingers left the piece I
realized I'd Blended and I just sat
there and I was kind of like nodding
looking confident my opponent had two
minutes on the clock and I was looking
his most obvious move pushing a point to
F3 I was looking at the F3 Square being
like yep because his winning move was on
the other side of the board and smart
yeah he went down to five seconds I was
like oh he's gonna play it and then he
didn't nice oh that's a good idea so
yeah it was the opposite of Poker Face I
knew I had to react but I knew I had to
pretend I was confident yeah that's okay
the queen shuffles yeah and uh talking
about someone who wasn't Poker Face I
mean there was a quite a famous uh
incident that happened in Norway chess
this year where Anand he was playing
against chakra or mamajarov and he just
blundered he just blundered him and uh
he would he resigned you know he was so
shocked with this blunder there were
Mama jar of came back it just like
literally shook his hand and the farmer
Jeffer said like Shaq was like why why
has he resigned and then it took him a
while and then
I would have seen that and we were like
we're not so sure actually because maybe
he would have made a quick move when he
came back and there was a very natural
move at his disposal as well so it was
not entirely clear that that her Shaq
would have found the winning
continuation and afterwards we were
discussing this uh at the end of the
tournament and Mishi agreed with me
premature it was an emotional resume it
was yeah
so this can never happen because it's
logistically impossible to set up but to
measure blund is made on returning from
the toilet because that's when I feel
like I'm making I make it most of that
but you would have to know when a plague
well you could do it on the tour
potentially if they have a toilet break
or if it's very very rare it's quite
difficult to do but I always feel like I
made huge blunders just coming back from
a toilet break or just going out so
because I've
I've not fully gathered myself and I
kind of rush into the position yeah or
immediately after getting the bonus time
that's the classic isn't it that's the
first one 41 yeah
the famous move 41. Take Your Eye Off
the Ball you've just had your toilet
break probably yeah you normally sit
there for 10 20 minutes and unfocused
and that's where the mistakes happen
yeah move 40 that's the time control
in most games I guess it's lucky for the
players to get bonus time after every
move uh every move 10 seconds
Vincent way down on the clock here I
mean he's eight minutes down he's got a
worse position this is just everything
the stars are aligning for Magnus here
just everything is working looks like
he's hustling in a way on the clock
Magnus like that's why he played that
blunder so quickly he's just trying to
put pressure on the clock as well
um it'll be fascinating to find out
whether he can if he's aware that he
made a mistake later maybe that's
something we can ask the Norwegian if we
can get him for an interview yeah
meanwhile White's Rook going on the
attack but it's attacking alone White's
Bishops are completely blocked in that's
why the evaluation Bar says it's so good
for black and now Magnus
cynical just swapping one of those
Bishops off makes sense
the white Pawns in the sense the white
doubled e pawns look very very weak yeah
and this will secure his Rook now but is
there a little Tick Tock uh no that's
not the fact Rook Ada this is one of my
favorite tactics the interference active
Bishop D4 does that exist so in the
current position sorry if yes we're
coming across the bishop now cutting the
connection between the two Rooks
if this bishop is captured for example
Pawn takes then The Rook Falls but I
guess you can just support your Rook
ah yeah I missed that actually see the
rook's not trapped I think maybe he's
looking the other direction Lawrence
maybe he wants to go this way and start
attacking the king yeah
this is slightly awkward to deal with
potentially
um you don't really want to go passive
with the black queen to defend you can
move the Black Knight out the way for
example uh just to defend across but
slightly slightly loose maybe for black
temporarily I could envisage a situation
where I had a Trader pawns at least
white has some tricks some counterplay
at least now all of White's pieces are
pointing towards the black king
yeah I wasn't actually sure about Bishop
D3 when Magnus played it because the
bishop wasn't doing very much I thought
he was just going to dabble on the
d-line and earlier this move yeah yeah
instead of this move just to move like
Rook D6 or Rook A7 some doubling and ask
because this Rook on G3 is really quite
poor
um
the sort of move I would play so I know
it's not very good um
through with your plan and now David's
question is going to be on the board the
Queen is going to come up thread and
checkmate
I mean
yeah makes sense what else do you do
with weight
completely clear
why not go threaten Checkmate I think I
think you have to do this I mean White's
been looking at ways to initiate chaos
from quiet
some moves ago so now I'm thinking
but I mean how
how to keep control
he plays this move big threat on the
board yeah Queen takes Pawn it's gonna
be Checkmate so you can't allow that and
David kind of showed that the Knight can
Retreat
um there's also the queen that can
retreat but at the same time they kind
of does feel like white is gaining some
momentum yeah yeah and tough pieces
lined up against the black king right
yeah and I'm just thinking that uh the
pawn on E5 can be destabilized and the
the Bishops die
potential on the dot on the long
diagonal can be nothing yeah the bishop
indirectly maybe attacking this Pawn
temporarily Black's got everything
covered but yeah I mean this rook's not
doing anything that's why I suggested
maybe just bringing it across and
there is potential to kind of switch
Focus double up on the open file to
break in there like you like I said
sometimes you can go for this Pawn
sometimes you can go maybe for this Pawn
I'm not entirely sure Magnus is happy
now it feels like he has lost
significant control okay Vincent doesn't
go for this last move instead bringing
his Queen in
maybe a threat on the board of quintix
Pawn utilizing the fact that g Pawn is
pinned for black
I would instinctively move my king out
of the firing line you move it onto this
Bishop's diagonal yeah
it's uh Vincent fighting very well all
right well so looking better for Vincent
on the board and it's definitely looking
good for Vincent on the standings after
two out of 15 rounds in the
preliminaries he has four points that is
one point more than Magnus Carlsen who
has uh won one game and lost one game on
three points Magnus Carlsen there are
four players on three players on four
points and one player with two wins
another backup there's a tour of six
points and it's looking good for him
also here in round three could he win
three out of three in the start of the
aim chess rapid that would be impressive
and just draw for Vincent in this game
would be impressive against Magnus
Carlsen rated at
29.02 in the tour
definitely the strongest Flair
playing some inaccurate moves over the
last few moves Magnus possibly it feels
like he's rushing and now the Black
Knight has jumped out the way this has
allowed the White Queen to swing across
and capture a pawn
and Magnus slight Shake of the head
there
um he's completely lost control so now
it's just very tactical very
um I mean it's very concrete the
position I guess Magnus was banking on
the fact that the black Rook could come
down and check the white king but after
a trade of Rooks White's King can
actually maybe just March towards the
center safely
suddenly black has no stability and you
need to I mean you need something now
otherwise
white might continue just grabbing some
Pawns
what do you guys think he's got 10
minutes should he just sit on his hands
and
kind of I don't know yeah Now's the Time
to have a pause yeah because you have a
check as you mentioned there's also a
knight takes Pawn in the air
um you have to decide which one is the
most
effective way of putting white under
some pressure
nurse how would you go about approaching
this position for black if you know
you've lost some control but it's still
very complicated
yeah it's a it's a it's a tough question
uh
yeah I think you do have to invest time
here I think this is the moment where
we're going to see Magnus investing
something in the region of three or four
minutes because there's a lot of forcing
calculation baselines which you just
have to
check and recheck
and you've got lots of I mean there are
there are probably four candidate moves
minimum here for blacks so it's it's a
really tricky but Magnus is he's not yet
firing as he is he's not in the fifth
gear that we're used to when he gets
there he's almost unbeatable but he's
certainly not there yet and Vincent will
be mildly optimistic here about at least
getting I'm not I don't I'm not sure
Vincent is thinking about winning this
position but I don't think he's thinking
he's losing now
so I mean in this position if it were me
if I'm calculating like you said there's
a rook check there's you can capture
this Pawn you can capture this Pawn in a
second way and there's a bunch of
options so I wouldn't start by looking
at the checks first I guess checks
captures the threats as we mentioned
earlier uh so this forces the opponent's
reply uh it forces the second reply as
well the king marching out into the open
but
the key is whether anything exists now
whether black has a follow-up white is a
pawn up temporarily this Pawn is
attacked as well there's now some checks
in the air the problem is if you check
with the black queen this can just be
blocked by White's Rook
and what next uh I just don't see a
follow-up so this is what Magnus is
calculating he's looking at this
position first maybe uh and he's just
trying to figure out if there's a
continuation you could still perhaps
continue here in a few ways if that
doesn't work if that doesn't appeal to
him he'll go back he'll look at the
second candidate move which is a capture
now this is maybe a bigger threat but it
does give white some time
exactly sure what white would do here
for example if white were to just
there's a rook across I was going to say
to the square but
doesn't guard against the track maybe
for example the white Rook would just
swing across now the black book can't
give a check
maybe there's nothing here either and
that's why Magnus is just pausing and
raising his eyebrows it looks like on
the camera
but uh yeah no easy move you can take
this Pawn With The Rook as well but it's
not clear what that gains
yeah Magnus is it's not often you have
Magnus Carlsen stumps but he's he's a
bit stumped in this position you you saw
him breathe out heavily
um
he's not happy he's
he's annoyed that he's let this one get
a little out of control because he had
such such a good grip on the position
just five ten moves ago plays the move
Knight takes E3 okay
and yeah I mean this black Rook check
now is much more scary
so white I guess has to deal with it
computer hated that move by the way
really computer just went nuts at that
move evaluation bar now in Vincent's
favor for the first time I don't
remember if it goes over is it one or
two after two that's where the advantage
capitalization not quite yet what was it
nearly 90 or right over 90 it wasn't 91
91 yeah if he gets if the bar goes that
far how far did it go with that one
moment where Magnus blundered was it
plus two it might have been yeah last
two yeah yeah so that might affect his
stats
down to 90 now yeah but still you know
the position is massively complicated
and Vincent doesn't have that much time
to navigate this you know just over two
minutes on the clock
oh and Magnus should spend more time in
the mountains or in the Swedish Woods I
don't know where he is because his uh
everything's uh starts very nice air
quality great there in the cabin in
Sweden oh even the temperature even the
temperature yeah it normally has it
pretty warm yeah
the dark where he is I don't approve of
that but air quality being good yeah
nice nice the chest of course we've seen
that directly impact players results in
WoW Vincent this shows nerves of Steel
just capturing a pawn Vincent going a
pawn up again but allowing some
dangerous tracks
Oh What A Brave guy
the black Rook can come down now again
with a check maybe there's just no
follow-up taking those risks is that
what he's doing it looks that way he
really wants to win this game there were
safer options as I mentioned uh you
could have stopped any checks in this
position for example you could bring a
rook across attacking the Knight
stopping any checks but uh Vincent just
grabs a pawn and now okay the key
question is after this one after a trade
of Rooks White's King notching forward
into the open is there a follow-up
now maybe not again I don't see anything
I think the Rook just blocks
ah yeah I mean another night check the
king just moves and there's always a
double attack against the queen now and
against The Rook
I think he uh I think Magnus has to
maybe reject this line that you have on
the board I think that's this track yeah
and uh perhaps introduce a new piece
into the attack maybe move the koi I'm
thinking moving to the F7 Square first
of all to God the king but also at the
same time now threaten this Rook track
which will be quite deadly now a massive
threats of Rook check because the queen
cuts off the king's Escape Route and I
guess if the Rook shuffles across to
block that file then we could see the
queen introduce a second threat yeah
yeah let's throw down Checkmate now that
was the plan yeah I mean this makes a
lot of sense Ivanka also it's quite nice
to block any Queen tracks along this
diagonal for white
um
what would Vincent have in store here
I do wonder whether at some point he
might just give up his Rook for the
Black Knights and just say okay I'm just
gonna go grab it this Pawn next I'll
grab this Pawn
still it's so hard to evaluate who's got
the advantage here long term it's white
if the Queen's come off maybe but yeah
in this one though I don't think it
works right because rookie 2 Queen G6
and still the white king Under Fire okay
Magnus goes the other way uh instead in
this position he brings his Queen to the
H4 Square
what's the queen doing here maybe
hitting this Pawn Maybe
some ideas still of this check and maybe
also the night retreating to the G4
Square so you can
oh it's getting greedy grabbing all the
pawns now Vincent has a huge threat on
the board as well Rook takes Pawn
this position is crazy it really is how
is it 0.0 here because it looks like
someone either for instance just two
pawns up and about to win or uh or
Vincent's getting checkmated there's
there's a really important variation
here which is where after Rook down
check take take King F2 Knight G4 check
looks as though black wins the bishop
but after let's say
uh but King eats who hits The Rook but I
yeah I wanted to show that after Knight
takes E5 white has also got a resource
of checking on the back rank he can also
of course he would take the Rook here
but checking down there and winning that
night so Vincent aware of the resources
incredibly tough position for both
players Magnus needs some magic now
because
I mean this is just a whoops Rook takes
porn sorry it's a winning threat the
black king will have nowhere safe to go
if that happens
so Magnus I guess he can block this with
ivanka's idea by dropping the Knight
back wait one second I just have to
interrupt you there David because
there's only one move to save the game
and that's the play Queen takes Pawn
allow the rock to take the pawn with
check and then the whole idea oh my God
this this move is just crazy and then
the whole point is that you hide the
king along the same diagonal as the
bishop move it into the Hague Square so
you walk into a discover check you just
don't care and you say come at me whoa
the problem here is that it's so
unnatural how do you put your king in
the corner here opposite your opponent's
Bishop so Magnus only has this one move
to not lose the game everything else
will lose here he has to take this Pawn
on e4
and that is not obvious I guess the
justification is here you can walk into
the firing line because you're attacking
the piece that will check the black king
but for example after The Rook drops
back with a check the black king has to
go to this square and at the very least
Vincent has a draw so even if Magnus
finds the only defense Vincent has a
draw
do you think you'll find it
I mean if anybody can find it it's it's
him he takes Pawn I mean it's such a
hard move to play walking into it
firstly you walk in to check and then
you have to walk into a discover check
it's your worst nightmare
thinking for over two minutes two and a
half minutes now Magnus he has to find
this move will he find it
so Queen takes Pawn
we're looking for that one he's under
three minutes now
I have a feeling he won't I don't think
I would play this move I don't think I
mean it would be on my radar but once I
see that I have to walk into the corner
or
I think I'll just write it off
especially with only three minutes maybe
if you have half an hour you see this
it's just goes he doesn't find it it's
Magnus now losing this game he is losing
he actually plays the second best move
we saw the stock fish suggestions there
but it gives white a massive Advantage
3.7
why is two pawns off so it's not
actually that surprising uh the white is
winning it's just Vincent now just needs
to solidify why is it winning so what's
the what's the variation of anchor
because it's still still okay maybe you
can just straightforward two two ways to
to win the position on only two ways I
have to say it's actually to move the
queen to this the C6 Square as you've
highlighted or to give a check two moves
so either you give a check with the
queen uh or maybe the most natural move
I'm only playing this because I I know
that this was Black's best move on the
last go so you can move your queen to
this square and guard your Central Pawn
and he doesn't oh no okay now it's been
turned around now black is going to win
what look at that so can I take this
Pawn first of all that is one question
maybe you can maybe this is just the key
for Magnus this Pawn getting it's not
just the pawn it's getting the Queen's
centralized and he does take it now this
is a monster threat now the white king
is not safe and Black's King
surviving just about
I mean it's just the clock Vincent uh
didn't have enough time there to work
things out but just a bit greedy I guess
with this last Pawn capture
and uh what to do now for example this
check can simply be met by the king
running to the side the Black Brook does
a great defensive job
the evaluation bar only says plus 1.3 so
there must be a way for Vincent to keep
alive
keep the fight going
okay he moves this Rook across very
natural this Knight is pinned now uh in
this direction but it doesn't stop the
black root from coming down and why is
Black's moves are so natural that's the
problem you just go for the white king
your two pawns down you just go all in
and
objectively it's good for black that
makes magnus's task easier and if the
white king is being forced to run out
into the open and there's a queen and a
rook and a knight where the queen and
Knight I have to say our magnificent Duo
this time it won't end well for white I
guess you can just give a check with
your Rook for example and the king is
doomed 10 seconds for Vincent Carmer
yeah 10 seconds and not easy okay he
drops his Bishop back to defend his Rook
it's uh this one it does now look very
bad for white
still need to knock uh The Knockout blue
how would you knock out your opponent
Lawrence
um you know left hook to the body left
upper you know
that's what I was thinking I was
thinking either you come this way and
keep things simple attack The Rook or
you can maybe take this Pawn attacking
The Rook
cute mate we're attacking this rook and
three times yeah cute mate here uh this
is checkmate
King trapped on the back rack
and these moves will be on magnus's
radar
um they're not that difficult either he
just drops back okay makes sense
blocking the Rooks path towards the
yeah exactly geometry
um using the queen to try and trade off
the black's Queen but also indirectly
protecting your Rook
wow that's not obvious maybe this is
what magnets missed oh it's like they're
walking a tightrope over
the Grand Canyon or something they just
have to find these only moves and
they're talking about only moves I just
picked up the computer's evaluation and
there you can see it only one move to
save
and Magnus has to trade off Rooks and
that's not obvious he doesn't actually
want to trade off pieces he's two pawns
down he wants to keep the attack going
somehow I have a feeling he's not going
to play that he'll want to play
something
a bit more ambitious like moving the
queen but uh Rook takes Rook does look
like the only way wow
okay he doesn't play it he goes plays
the flashy move attacking the White
Queen now the bishop cannot capture
because this would end in Checkmate but
why is this bad can we work it out and
now 9.5 for Winston kymer well Rook
takes Knight I mean what a move this
this is hanging uh this is hanging this
is hanging but White's defending
everything
maybe there's something better I mean
can he take the work which one this one
or this one is so complicated right now
um if you take this Rook with a check
I guess you can take this Rook now this
is the minimum for black you can take
yeah so now it's Rook versus Bishop in
two pawns it's actually level material
after all of that and what gives the
track it should now be a draw with best
player most likely
um but White's King is still in a bit of
trouble Black's got two heavy pieces
I just want to backtrack and find out
what the winning move was in this
position
because it's just chaotic it's gonna
play Queen uh Queen F3 in the I guess we
should stay with the current position
maybe it was just a simple check and
then you pick up the stroke but uh okay
let's go back to the current position as
you mentioned Lawrence this is a great
move bar is going up for Magnus again
yeah bars going up for black but you
know there are a lot of these end games
where the bar says plus 1.1 or 1.2 but
it's actually a theoretical draw
for example here you could have traded
the queens and then gone down to pin and
then try to go across maybe there's some
chances here but
um okay yeah he just went back yeah I
think it's a very smart idea not to
exchange off Queens because then you
keep the dangerous Dynamic potential
that the rook and Queen have against
White's exposed King yeah people you can
already gain time against the White
Queen forcing her away okay Magnus plays
a nasty trick uh bringing the queen in
The Rook is poisoned if you capture The
Rook you get distracted from your Bishop
winning I mean it looks really strong
because after all the Rook is going to
that's a threat
yeah okay now I think uh Vincent has
lost control you know I think his
position has totally collapsed one Pawn
has dropped White's King is out in the
open
it's all about this King uh this Pawn as
well not long for the world and then
it's just Brook versus Bishop
Advantage winning for black
take a break because yeah that's just
chaotic wow but is Magnus winning now
yes yeah and it's relatively
straightforward okay I promise he has no
counter play Vincent's the black king
can easily hide behind its Pawns
um it's just a mopping up job as we say
and yeah I mean if the Queens are off
the board maybe still a draw
but with the Queen's on white king is
the target yeah and I just love the way
that Magnus just attacks the queen but
at the same time his Rook is protected
the queen is nicely positioned to guard
the king I mean Magnus knows how to make
his pieces work together as a team
I think Winston's going to lose on time
here oh we got there just one second he
made that move woof there's the Trap
they're greedy and go and capture
White's Pawn now because the White Queen
will go to f8 check and hit that black
Rook
okay still surviving
Magnus loves to centralize his Queens in
these end games
very sensible
two threats now
um well at least the biggest one is to
bring the Rook down to the first rank
that white Bishop oh a bunch of games
have finished we did see a win for uh
Mama diara on fire today he beats the
Magnus Carlsen and now in round three he
beat anishigiri I did see a tweet
apparently sacrificing a queen a rook a
knight I think there was even one more
piece in that game to beat Anish giri I
mean mom and yarov on fire sounds like a
standard game it does
yeah and uh Magnus just setting up for
the final attack
centralizing his pieces
I mean I wouldn't be surprised if Magnus
just puts his King I was gonna say on a
light Square just so it doesn't get
checked
setting the traps of instant again that
pawn is poisoned uh if you take that
pawn with the black queen white will
play Queen F5 check hitting the black
king winning the Black Brook
I mean don't rush yeah don't rush I mean
now is it time to line up the rook and
the queen together
on the on the e-line
packing the bishop yeah
the White Queen as well with the black
Rook you can pin that white Bishop
what's nice about Rook E3 also your
Rangers after King F1 you want Wayne I
know
so there you go setting all the traps
backwards uh back
or backwards uh yeah yeah we'll see a
resignation at any moment for Vincent he
can't keep everything together Bishop's
just a bad piece he
and that rook's coming to E2 let's come
back to the second round four seconds
and uh he moves his Bishop to the edge
of the board but that's it it's going to
be game over
yeah The Rook just moves it's going to
come to the first Rank and pin that
White Queen
I might just doesn't have enough Pawn
shelter for his King
okay he Retreats he's still fighting
Fair Play credit to Vincent there but
yeah what a game this has been just uh
this feels like the calm after the storm
but Magnus
how does he do it just balancing on the
edge of that tightrope all the time and
just somehow he wins these positions
okay how to finish this one off yeah
there's still work here actually
taking to 30 seconds Magnus Carlson
Vincent Keim are probably losing this
game but he's been on the fire lately
and reached 2700 and over the board
chess made it to the semi-finals in the
previous tournament and his fellow
German Matthias bluebound I think he's
ready for the Fisher random World
Championship later this month with for
example Magnus Carlsen chess in Germany
is booming you're living in Germany
Lawrence yeah is there a lot of positive
attention around chess right now in
Germany
um yeah I would say
you know there's a number of very strong
young players and really Vincent you
know being
only 17 2700 but there are a small group
they were called the German princes or
maybe they still are called the German
princes uh you know you had Rasmus
whanau Matas blue balm
um Wagner a bunch of young players who
got very very good they didn't quite
break these super Elite though like
Vincent has done
um
but
there's still time they're still young I
mean it would be great for chess right
if uh if chess got super popular in
Germany such a what the big and
important country the German Federation
are working towards that and their whole
goal is to raise the standard they don't
want just one player to be exceptional
they want there to be like the Russians
like the Indians you know where you have
a group of them and so they're prepared
to dive invest their energies and
resources into creating these
foundations that can accelerate
improvements right and it seems like
Magnus is treating us to a grind
or maybe an entry into yours into your
testable course winning the long way
and I mean he could have probably just
found a Checkmate earlier but uh he
decided to go into the same game and it
is winning especially because the white
pawns are fixed on the same color as
their Bishop meaning that the black king
has an easy route towards those pawns
later
but uh he's not made it easy for himself
Magnus he's definitely played subpart
this game this has been a pretty poor
game for his standards yeah I mean
I think it's a very realistic game you
know uh I I can see myself in this type
of game you know you know you have a
winning position you don't quite put the
boot in and then you're forced to grind
this out you know it's been very
topsy-turvy you know missing chances
left right and Santa
and I don't know one of the advantages
of it being a long game is that uh well
everyone at home can send in their
Twitter suggestions or their tweets yeah
they're who they're cheering for their
selfies and uh of course we still maybe
have time to
analyze someone's ingest statistics yeah
I'm gonna do that after this game a
viewer at home will get their
performance analyzed by David I will not
have to say I love the reasons for a lot
of people a lot of people like oh I want
to break 1400 we've seen some people say
hey it's my birthday wink week
and some people have gone down the
flattery route they'll say oh we love
David
flattery gets you yeah
are we going to see a beautiful check
mating
we're gonna see it aren't we I think we
are the white king is just trapped
eternally oh he needs to are you
thinking of the one I'm thinking oh no
there's a cute one that she's oh okay
let's show this pack The Rook yeah and
uh will we see Vincent resign let's keep
an eye on the players if the bishop okay
the bishop drops just wait just move
your rook and Magnus is going to do this
now wherever the bishop goes he's gonna
bring his Rook back uh The Bishop's
gonna move and he's going to give up his
rook and deliver checkmate with a pawn
what a finish and Vincent resigns he
knew this was coming ah he should have
shown us the chat mate but there we go
Magnus eventually takes the win
it's over another one four minus crawls
in a long grind and what an interesting
game so many one moves that these
players had to find eventually Magnus
Crossman was the one who found the most
important ones to win this uh game and
it is time now for today's Lisa vetta
learning